I have what I guess is called invisible
illness so I don't look sick I've had
this problem even when I had my
endometriosis was really bad and I was
getting I was having a lot of
gastrointestinal issues I was losing
weight I remember going to my this was
when I was in college going to the
doctors there and then just not
believing I was sick they accuse me of
being bulimic they were like you're
probably just don't want to eat and I
was like no I'm sick to my stomach I
don't know what's wrong I'm in pain all
the time but they were just like you
don't look sick look at how healthy your
hair is no one who is in pain could have
hair as nice as you I've been told that
by doctors and I've had similar things
not as egregious as that as I've gotten
older where it's like well you can walk
and you're not in a wheelchair and you
don't you have you don't you have nice
teeth or you have nice hair you're too
young to have back problems I've had one
doctor say then people don't have the
back problems you seem to be having and
it's like well I have those back
problems so you see my MRI you see I
have disk issues so there's a lot of
there's new advocacy around this idea of
you know just because you can't plainly
see that a person is in pain ER is
disabled that doesn't mean they don't
have illness or disability but it's
still very hard and I sometimes feel
like even with doctors I have to really
argue with them like I'm in a lot of
pain and even though you know I'm
standing here and I'm not crying and I
don't you know not in a wheelchair I'm
in pain and then there's the the one
through ten thing tell me how much pain
you're in and it's really hard if you
live with chronic pain is your daily
reality because it's harder to gauge
because it's like well this is my daily
reality you kind of adapt a little to
the pain and it's like well if this pain
was brand-new I'd be in the emergency
room but I live like this every day so I
guess it's for me now five but when I
first started getting it was an eight or
nine but it's still bad it's just I've
lived with it every day
and I know now I'm not dying from it but
so I those those ones attendings can be
really deceiving because you don't you
don't even know what to tell doctors
when it's something you live with every
single day